negotiate a path to peace that allows
Ukraine to come out with its sovereignty
intact well what does that sovereignty
look like to you a hard commitment that
NATO will not admit best sovereignty
what does that sovereignty look like to
you answering the question whenever
you're tell me when you're done and then
I'll answer the question answer the
question NATO will not admit Ukraine to
Nato and should not admit Ukraine to
Nato because we made a commitment in
1990 and I believe in standing by our
commitments that NATO would not expand
one inch not one inch past East ger
made a commitment that it would not
expand his
territory what I want to say is I'm very
glad that young people are engaged and
passionate about these issues so the
fact of the matter is I believe it St
our commitments but the job of the US
president to look after us interests and
have a reasonable path to peace the is
the most gracious about answering
people's questions debating openly and
he's trying to answer the question and
this kid won't stop speaking